With more than ten million teachers trained in 70 countries,...
...Intel Teach continues to prepare the next generation:...
...to learn, to lead and to participate in the global economy.
It definitely changed the way we teach.
It made the students feel more motivated and eager to learn.
My kids no longer learn for the sake of exams.
They learn because it's fun to learn.
Teachers change lives for the better,...
...having a lasting impact on the students in their classroom,...
...and the communities in which they serve.
Use of technology in the learning process enhanced the confidence level of young girls from poor areas...
...and made them realize that they are also part of this progressive society and can do wonders.
It encourages students to create and innovate.
It cultivates teamwork, creativity and problem - solving skills using ICT as tools of learning.
It has allowed me to leave an impression on my students,...
...which inspires them to seek improvement day by day.
Intel Teach continues its mission to empower students for success in the 21st century.
Ten million teachers trained,...
...countless classrooms reinvented;...
...great teaching enriches us all.